we have a really rapidly growing discussion
forum on Reddit. It is The David Pakman Show
Subrata now with nearly 30000 of our viewers
and listeners subscribed for free. You can find
it at David Pakman dotcom slash Reddit. A few
interesting posts I spotted this morning. One
is a post called We Defeated the Flu, amazingly,
and it's a screenshot of a Dr. Drew tweet. Now,
Dr. Drew has told some whoppers uncovered in the
past, but he is right about this. And Dr. Drew
tweeted, Amazingly, only one hundred and sixty
five patients have been hospitalized with the flu
in the United States since October. Last season,
we had four hundred thousand hospitalizations. The
staggering difference may be due to better hygiene
practices, changes in the bacterial gradient
field. Either way, continue washing your hands.
Well, Dr. Drew is sort of right here. I mean, what
we know is that coronavirus is more contagious
than the flu. It's are not it's reproduction rate
is when it's unmitigated is higher than
the flu. If you are able to take measures
that prevent the spread of the flu by sheer
mathematical reality, you are also going to
prevent the spread of less contagious things.
Because we are taking measures, many of us,
we have been to stop the spread of coronavirus.
The flu, which is less contagious, has been all
but completely destroyed. I read I think it was
I'm going from memory here. I believe it's that in
the UK there's only been one pediatric flu death
where normally at this point in the flu season,
there would be way, way, way more. So it's
very difficult to find anything good out of
this pandemic which has been so destructive. Maybe
the the advance and kind of putting into reality
Maryna based vaccines would be something that
would be good and would be available in the future
for dealing with other diseases. That that's a
possibility. It's hard to find anything positive,
but certainly the absolute destruction, I would
say decimation, but I think we've done even better
than 90 percent reduction in the flu season
has been absolutely fantastic. Another post
I spotted this morning on the sub, read it from
a user named Copp Cooper Moss who says, the flag
at my local Wal-Mart is at half staff. And I think
it was to honor Rush Limbaugh writing that, quote,
I'm a truck driver and deliver to this particular
Wal-Mart Wal-Mart store in Oregon and notice that
the flag is at half staff. Now, I can't find any
info online as to any official statement from
the state as to why other than the whole flag
debacle. I also know the manager of the store
is really conservative and looks like he could
be Russia's fatter, shorter brother. I feel like
it shouldn't be up to the store managers personal
feelings as to when the flag is lowered or raised.
Maybe I'm overreacting, but for context, about
a year ago, a driver was crushed to death when
a forklift rolled over him and people barely spoke
about it the next day. Never saw the flag lowered
to respect someone who literally died working for
you. But a homophobic radio personality across the
country deserves that honor. Listen, I don't know
what's going on at this store. Joe Biden ordered
flags lowered for five days in commemoration
in memory of the 500000 coronavirus deaths.
In theory, the timing at this Wal-Mart could
be over that, although if it's a hard core
right wing store manager, I don't know. But
there's actually a lot of stories of really random
and relatively obscure places, even lowering
their flags in honor of Rush Limbaugh. And,
yeah, I think that Rush Limbaugh was a terrible
influence on this country and on this planet. But
you are seeing a lot of people who want to honor
his memory as if he did something good, which is.
Really destructive and sad to see, join the
discussion on The David Pakman Show sub,
read it at David Pakman dot com
slash redit. That's R.E.D. Dite